well that was fun but I gotta say it's
nice to get some rest and relaxation ah
masked intruder what take whatever you
want just please don't rape me what okay
that's the way it has to be if you have
to do what you have to do understand me
it is the way ha ha critic it's it's me
Todd oh yeah that's right the mask thing
are you doing here
remember we're here to shoot a crossover
scheduled with your secretary like a
week ago do you mr. McCready do not
forget about your appointment with
Pittman oh it's just you know my
schedules been so crazy I barely had
time for crossovers hey don't forget man
we're doing Pink Floyd's the wall 5
minutes
God I'm telling the security in this
hotel it's just that you know your
review music and you know musics just
not really my thing
well I'm few movies too if they're
terrible and they start famous pop
singer and I have just the movie for us
Michael Jackson's magnum opus move
Walker did it cool as ice did a glitter
you did it seriously man I gotta start
watching my own stuff doors over there
Hamburglar no wait
Wiz you're a sick fuck with a shoe you
know the movie the wig
in 1973 Broadway rolled out the smash
hit musical The Wiz a new musical
version of The Wizard of Oz and the
twist in this case was that the
soundtrack was funkier and the cast was
all-black it was a smash hit black
audiences loved it
white audiences loved it everyone loved
it five years later Motown Records got
to hold the film rights and cast the two
biggest singers on its roster the
legendary Diana Ross and the quickly
becoming legendary Michael Jackson
not only that they loaded up with all
the greatest black performers they could
find Lena Horne Richard Pryor that guy
from The Match Game and that goes for
the talent behind the camera too after
all who better to bring black America to
the whimsical fantasy scape of Oz then
director of angry social drama Sidney
Lumet and a screenplay from the guy who
brought us the bat credit card oh gosh
schumacher seriously was he put bat
nipples on the Tin Man come on it's a
great play it's a great iconic story who
could screw that up
schumacher can find a way everything he
touches turns to dick and that's not a
reference to his homosexuality I think
he's just a terrible storyteller well
come on let's watch the movie we're off
to annoy the critic nostalgia critic in
let's watch the movie so we open in
Harlan well total we really aren't in
Kansas anymore okay apparently we see
Dorothy's family having dinner party and
singing a song but Dorothy instead sings
a song about how she's scared and she
doesn't know why what am I afraid of
don't know what I'm made of
okay wait her first song is about being
scared
uh this isn't exactly somewhere over the
rainbow is it something tells me that
it's more than I can deal with
in fact it's exactly the opposite that's
like if they remade Beauty and the Beast
and instead of be our guest they sung
get the fuck out also she's a
kindergarten teacher but auntie em think
she should teach high school to make
more money now you take that new job and
find a place for you in total it's time
for you to make a home of your own
remember there's no place like home
unless you're 24 and you have a job in
which case move out you fucking
freeloader in whatever your fears are
will there be defeated just by face it
up - okay
I'm confused cuz I've seen the Wiz my
high school dinner production of The Wiz
this is not the Wiz I don't know what
the hell this is it's been a while but
I'm pretty sure Dorothy was still a
little girl
and she definitely lived on a farm in
Kansas not New York why change that like
what the hell is the difference like to
make it appeal to black people you know
there are black farmers schumacher right
well here's something that didn't change
Toto is still the world's most suicidal
dog forcing Dorothy to chase after him
so of course then she get swept away by
a tornado in New York during a raging
snowstorm
you know blizzard tornadoes happens all
the time in New York along with the
earthquake volcanoes well you know the
drill she's being swept away to the
wonderful world of Oz wait a minute this
is Oz Munchkinland is a lousy concrete
playground yeah looks kind of crappy I
mean go back and look at the original
she lands in Oz the world turns colorful
and there's this amazing new place but
this place looks like Gotham City and
Schumacher's Batman movies hey maybe
that's where he got the artistic
direction for those buildings what do we
agree out complimenting Joel Schumacher
while you're still alive and here we
have this movie's version of the
Munchkins apparently played by the cast
of what's happening they were turned
into graffiti but were saved when
Dorothy recklessly manslaughter the evil
witch that cursed them so if you know
the original the plot of this one
shouldn't be a surprise they tell her
that she needs to go find the yellow
brick road and find the Wiz not the
wizard just the Wiz so I figured the
odds are only the Wiz could
Sipho how to get you back to witches in
that place where is what so is well I
don't want to get too dirty but there's
a reason the yellow brick road is yellow
don't piss on me electric fence they
sing a song about how great the Wiz is
but ok is it just me or does it sound
like this song belongs in Sesame Street
he's the man he's the only one and give
your wish
right the year he'll send you back to
time by running magic through yeah
because the Wiz is a person in your
neighborhood in your neighborhood in
your neighborhood and I'm sure you know
there's an urban legend that if you look
closely in the background you can
actually see Motown's film division
committing suicide follow the yellow
brick road the yellow brick road yeah
okay so she knows what to do and now
it's time to get the story rolling I'm
acting just like a baby
or stay in the exact same spot I sing
some more
I'm not sure that I'm aware if I'm up
down now then a hurry to get home huh
just going to see the way is when you're
up and ready for it again not a slam
against his homosexuality don't wanna be
afraid just don't be okay I am really
not feeling Diana Ross as Dorothy here
how did they take one of the most
glamorous and beautiful women of the 70s
and make it look that busted I guess it
doesn't help that she's constantly
whimpering and simpering like that I
mean look at her it'd be one thing if
she were a little girl like she was
supposed to be but she's not she's
clearly a woman in her mid-30s
I don't wanna go home I wanna go home
goddamn you're a grown-ass human being
man the fuck up or woman the fuck up
grow some balls or parade your vagina
put some hair on your chest
or shave your tits also she can't catch
a cab social commentary everyone
behold the magical dreamlike fantasy
world of Oz I'm not sure how respectful
it is to black audiences to make their
version of oz look like complete shit
it's almost as if Schumacher doesn't do
adaptations well so Dorothy comes across
a gang of crows they were apparently
taking a break from heckling Dumbo so
that they can bother the Scarecrow
played by Michael Jackson who at this
point was still black enough to be in
this movie just to take a walk in my
garden we're not big terrific fellas wow
you came whoa why are you just a straw
paper dummy his deal is that the crows
have destroyed his self-esteem by
constantly telling him he's dumb and
also that someday he'll look like this
ccero wife roll roll our men are noble
fight study than by nature in this movie
the Scarecrow is also constantly pulling
out quotes from his body
I don't want to see Michael Jackson pull
up anything from his body you gotta look
read it to you getting into shit get me
iterate and syncopate oh hell yeah
man I can't wait to see what dance moves
Michael pulls out in this one it's gonna
do like a moon Walker the Thriller dance
people keep saying
things are gonna change but they'll look
just like to stay in the same or you
could bounce around on that pole well
it's a great idea take one of the most
exciting dancers of our generation in
time to a pole here's my question
if this Oz is supposed to be like a
schizo version of New York why is there
a cornfield
you know the 59th Street cornfield but
next to the bridge
Dorothy chases off the crows and
promises them that the Wiz can get him a
brain so they go off to finding okay why
exactly can't they catch a cab because
they're black but everyone's black in
this unit whatever and that will lead us
to the plays best known best loved just
all-around best song ease on down the
road I can't wait to see how they do
this
come on get on down the road well you
know the scene in the original movie of
Dorothy and her friends kipping down the
yellow brick road is just so I kind of
get amazing but I've got this great idea
about how to improve it uh why don't we
film this scene 300 feet away and point
the camera at their fucking backs I
don't need to see their faces just their
backs
that's right no camera motion just hold
it completely still FAC what are we
doing so close to this camera why don't
we just move to that for a quarter now
this is how you do a review you know
what actually let's see if we can get it
even further away further they then run
across the Tin Man when this world is a
piece of Coney Island animatronics he
said because he's being sat on by his
giant fat metal wife and also he has no
heart which he expresses in song why
what'd I do if I could suddenly feel and
to know once again what I feel is real
um maybe instead of a heart you should
ask the Wiz for a singing voice what
would I do if I could reach inside of me
and to know how it feels to say
I like what I see Motown the legendary
R&B record label who had access to some
of the greatest black musical talent
that's ever existed cast this role with
nipsey Russell oh fuck what's the
fastest metal mouth on the Midway frozen
today a seat cushion
oh no Sarge immoral to me what he gets
another song now yeah Michael Jackson
the King of Pop gets one solo
performance but nipsey Russell gets two
in a row so then they travel to out
front of the odds New York library say
what you wanna I'm here stake
another song already well again I guess
it has been under a minute
so is the Cowardly Lion supposed to be
like a pimp
he's got the pimp boots and the fur coat
I really don't think that's where
they're going with that Todd now shut up
a frickin us in trouble oh okay even
quivering lower lid Dorothy figures out
that the lines it was so they add the
line of the group and they ease on down
the road all the way down into the
subway but unfortunately a creepy
peddler decides to attack them
oh my god this is as scary as an actual
New York subway you know I can't tell if
this scene is really creative or
especially lazy I mean it's kind of neat
that parts of the subway come to life
but then again it's just parts of the
subway coming to life
you just put teeth on garbage cans
what's next a drawer that each people
okay so they escape the pointless
obstacle but unfortunately that leads
them to the bad part of Oz well of
course oh I'll get you my pretty there's
no place like home
okay some hotties babe oh my
I guess the Donna Summer bad girls here
are supposed to be the poppy fields
because they make Dorothy and the lion
fall asleep but then the other two
rushing to save them please don't beat
Dean oh please don't be dead oh all is
lost
and now a pries of The Wizard
show-stopping signature musical number
teen 18 18 18 18 18
teeny teeny teeny teeny teeny teeny
ah the light it feels so bad that he
totally botched that one so Dorothy
makes him feel better with ya picture I
can never gonna believe it another song
a lie
my
hey when they're supposed to be we could
wish somewhere apparently not because
after that it's smooth sailing for
Dorothy in the crude make it to the
Emerald City and they get to meet no is
okay now I know the Wizard of Oz is a
timeless classic but you know what will
make it even more timeless it more
classic shitty disco music okay this
song was not in the play a bunch of
these songs were not in the play there's
a lot more songs that are missing from
the play in fact the movie only barely
resembles the play why they want to make
a film out of the play at all if they
didn't like or even understand the play
till I change the color ring I don't
even know what this dance number is
about they sing about the trendy color
of the moment then the Wiz changes the
color and they sing about that I feel
like this is a social commentary about
something I just had no idea what the
fuck it is and while we're ranting what
the hell's with all the wide shots in
this movie why am i constantly looking
at scenes filled with nothing fucking
happening why shots are supposed to have
a point
damn it here is just like the cameraman
was too lazy to walk the camera any
closer I guess they're there to show off
the sets which are pretty amazing by
amazing I mean amazingly big but
unfortunately they're amazingly fake
looking too they may as well just have
filmed it's in a McDonald's Playland
yeah like go back and look at
Munchkinland what the hell's going on
back there they supposed to be in a
black hole what's with the Emerald City
these people live anywhere they just
stand here on this empty ass dance floor
all day well in one of the scenes from
the source material that they managed
not to screw up they meet though Wiz who
tell them that if they want favors from
him they had to go kill the Wicked Witch
who the movie has finally remembered to
put it
uh spoilers movie jeez Wow she's hideous
and she's so evil in this version she
runs a sweatshop in a horrible factory
when I wake up in afternoon which
pleases me to do don't nobody bring me
no bad news you can't be my best of
friends as opposed to pay dues but
nobody bring me no bad news actually
this Wicked Witch is a lot of fun even
that's what Jeff seems really into it
yeah I kinda want her to win so don't
nobody bring me no bad news so she finds
out about Dorothy and sends out her
flying monkeys the flying monkeys for
the record are the name of a motorcycle
gang in this movie why because this film
is committed to taking every single
fantastical element of Oz and flushing
it straight down the crapper
the monkey bikers catcher the four of
them and bring them into the factory
where because this is a kids movie the
witch starts straight up torturing them
well that's gruesome yeah magic kind of
wondering how the hell they're gonna get
out of it she pulls the fire alarm
that's the solution yeah okay the
original wicked witch also got hit by
water in her own castle but it was like
a glass or a bucket it was a small
amount it's not a giant a sprinkler
system installed friggin everywhere one
of her own slaves could have taken her
out by absent-mindedly tossing a
cigarette into the garbage or something
Crick's in this highly funded musical
the way to fix the situation is the same
way the Energizer Bunny took her out
still going and Dorothea was right there
the Wicked Witch intentionally plopped
her right on that spot with the fire
alarm in plain view of everyone and get
this her throne is a giant toilet god I
thought the aliens from sides were
stupid Oh God
everybody look around cousin I think I'm
actually starting to feel this movie
like everyone's happy everyone's dancing
there's a lot energy Dinah Roz has
finally lost that annoying
wiggle-wiggle-wiggle look on her face
yeah you know I'm starting to getting
into this final
the hell's going on I'm an adult
they unzip their own skin and dance
around in diapers why what am I looking
at a giant mass of black people wearing
loincloths
okay I can only assume Dorothea and
everyone lead before the orgy commence
isn't full and they sneak in the back
way into the Wizards room where they
find out the awful truth The Wiz is just
a stand-up comedian with a well
publicized cocaine problem sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
alright son
everything is Sam I'm it's true I'm a
phony and then Superman showed up and he
was like and he landed right in the
middle this big plane thank you so then
Dorothy realizes that they had what they
needed all along and she sings about
believing in yourself and then Glenda
the Good Witch finally shows up just
right the fuck out of nowhere and then
she sings a song about believing in
yourself
God movie quit dragging it out click
chicken babies to the wall yep those are
definitely babies believe in yourself
pit babies to the wall obviously I don't
know what's in you you'll have to find
that out for yourself you'll never find
it in the safety of this room there's a
whole world out there and you'll have to
begin by letting people see who you
really are
wait actually now that I think about it
what I ventured out into the world it
was full of killers subways and garbage
you know what just stay in here and
don't ever leave let's see you got air
conditioning you've got it good I'm
ready now and we move on finally to the
last musical number which is amazingly
the most in confidently staged of them
all it's just I Anna Ross staring
directly into your soul with nothing but
inky blackness behind her background
when that makes the tall trees bed
turning suddenly the snowflakes that
fall have a main name god this is worse
than the dying Carol bit from the Star
Wars Holiday Special
we hope Chewbacca's dad isn't watching
it jerking off you know how is it that
the Wiz brought out two Star Wars
Holiday Special references in this
Oh auntie em I had the most awful dream
and you weren't there and you weren't
there none of you were there oh I'm so
glad to be home I am still here why
haven't you moved out yet well that was
the Wiz it sucked
it snuck it sucked this movie was a huge
flop at the time and I can see why I
know there's a lot of people have fond
memories of this movie but honestly I
thought it was completely awful from
beginning to end it made a bunch of
bullshit change to the original story
every single one of them is for the
worst
Dorothy's awful Direction is awful and
the story is bogged down by a bunch of
draggy slow musical numbers I did like
some of the songs I guess but for the
most part it just blew it's lame it's
dated is but ugly and it makes no
goddamn sense it fails to understand the
Wizard of Oz so hard that it doesn't
even get them moral right well thanks
for doing the review absolutely anytime
get out well okay ah maybe now I can get
some rest relax
friggin ation hello everybody and
welcome to yet another Linkara nostalgia
critic crossover where we talk about the
swampthing movie
that might be alone come on it or not
you don't have down the road lift your
left foot up your rides ones down come
on legs keep moving don't you lose
good
bathroom teeny teeny teeny